what's up with all the cat instagrams I
mean I have cats now and we're so boring
that we're always people are like social
media social media and I'm like oh nice
to see another picture of me in my
office working you know and the cats are
delightful they just give me fodder for
the for the social side really kept up
our popular yeah and they're way more
popular at us yeah we have put some like
sick live photos up and they get like
3,000 likes I'm like Hello look at how
much air I'm getting in this jump and
then I like put like a blurry picture of
my cat people are like OMG OMG like like
like like like I like like 13,000 lights
for my dumb cat
I think there's an assumption when you
hit a certain level of success or
visibility you probably go through this
too you've been a you're a familiar face
on television now for like 20 years you
look 18 but it's like really weird I
feel 68 yeah that's not really do but I
think people imagine and sort of project
a certain type of lifestyle on you like
grocery shop I changed the litter box I
sit on the couch and watch Netflix 48
hours in the room I baked macaroni and
cheese out of a box still sometimes like
our lives are so normal with eight
studio albums in a massive world tour
underway normal isn't exactly how we
would describe Tegan and Sara's lives
you tell me like the sisters are
splitting their time between Canada and
the US dating American citizens which
means the u.s. election is on their
minds it's been a circus yeah at this
point it's going to continue to be a
circus I'm sure until election day
Donald supported the invasion of Iraq
wrong that is absolute wrong proved over
and over again Blanche that's awful sad
it's embarrassing we've been touring
around we've been reminding people to
get out and vote whatever you feel about
Trump or Hillary Clinton you know we're
the type of people that sort of focus on
look there's one candidate and we all
know it's Hillary's like then she cares
about everybody and the thing that's so
shocking to me about Trump is that he
really wants to make things better for
one tiny tiny group of people and it and
so where are our message has mostly just
been like let's just let's just focus on
getting through this election and then
let's work towards like repairing that
energy because it's like it's we've seen
it with Justin Trudeau here in Canada
we're so proud to see how United
everybody is how positive everybody's
we're like the Canadians being like
let's get things positive again